and was head on with cars that were
parked on Scenic going south and there
was a police officer on the yeah that
was me that was you uhhuh but she was
like ring her hair and then she's like
going well like not a care in the world
you know what's how's it going
today well
just what kind of you running you know
grocery shopping pilling bills just
adult adult things yeah so where were
you coming from if we're being honest I
am uh um on the way to pick up on my
friend and cuz like I don't like doing
things by myself because I high anxiety
so I like people coming on rides with me
so I was going to go pick her up so I
can go to The Dispensary get what I need
and then bring it back home if you want
to I can show you my medical card a
question do you have a prescription for
XX
bars
no have you taken
any all right hang tight get some gloves
because I believe they're sitting right
there in the driver
seat for me it pretty much stay
simple ma'am is your ID in your purse
yes it is all right I'll get it I'll get
it hey I said I'll get it stand over
there at the end of your car
do you hear me okay but if you are more
respectful about it if I'm just saying
I'm just saying all right if we're all
humans here if you were more respectful
about it I
just where's your idea at is it in here
can I look through my wallet well like
why are you through my
wallet no the thing is that's my
property you have no choice actually I
do because I found freaking Xanax bars
on your driver's seat if you want to
explain something explain
those girl the fact that you're just
looking through my they were in plain
view yep that makes it oh were they in
plain view yeah your butt was covering
okay here will you do me a favor and go
sit on the bumper of that car over there
um
what okay I just want to know what I was
doing in particular Okay the reason you
were pulled over um you were called in
as a possible drunk driver and from the
people that were calling in said that
you hit multiple things I haven't been
to the other side of your car or really
inspected your car yet to verify that
but um you were found you're you were
found here she's getting out with you we
you were called in as a drunk driver
okay upon contact she's finding things
that are illegal in your car so this is
kind of the development that we're going
okay so for right now while she's doing
her job we're going to give her some
space and we're going to go sit at the
front of that car okay no
okay that's fine you can I mean the
fenders can be hot I mean if you want to
sit on this bumper that's probably not
going to be as hot but the fenders get
hot ma'am over here please I've asked
you you're right it is your
car did she say yes or no I'm sorry she
started
talking hey I've asked you nicely you
asked me to be respectful didn't you
have I not been respectful with you and
you're not doing what I asked you okay
would you like to sit down on the grass
over there I can I sit down in my car no
you cannot if I just have like H my
hands up no you're not getting back in
your car you can sit on the grass over
there or we can sit in the back of this
car here whichever one you prefer
okay
the only thing I'm seeing is there's
some scratch and stuff right
there uh I'm going to get my phone no
you're not you're staying right here
okay but why can't I get my phone to
like at least have you're not getting
back in that car until they're done okay
but I feel like I should be able to it's
my right to like record anything that's
happening in my life everything's being
recorded right here I know but why can't
I recorded for myself you're not going
back in that car why can't I you can
request this cording you can come with
me to my car my phone is right on that
seat one of y'all can come to me to that
seat to get my car to let me videotape
cuz that is my human right that is the
bare minimum y'all can do so I can go to
my my phone is right there look on I do
um so you have any idea while we
here I apparently what man saying was I
was drunk
driving okay I take you wasn't drunk
driving no I'm not
out of curiosity has your car always
been like that in the
front yes I have
um yeah
honestly okay what happened first okay
you see this part of my car I
do um one day I came back from work like
just like was like getting off and shit
MH that was missing no how is it missing
it was
missing
um this side of my
car uh we have a
Chevrolet truck that's in its vintage
like it's my grandpa's like old school
Chevrolet truck so it's like you know
it's a biggest and my grandpa got like a
Jeep Cherokee that's also just like
built in the 1990s and then they got a
sidekick Su okay see or whatever it's
called yeah um so like yeah do I need to
get that F no I'm just curious I'm
talking to you briefly here when I got
here I saw your demeanor your actions
and all that stuff okay um now when I
talk to you even more and I'm looking at
some indicators right now okay I'm
looking at your pupils I'm looking at
your eyes and I think that you might be
on the influence of some type of
narcotic not alcohol but I believe in
narcotic I understand okay um So based
off what I'm seeing so far would you be
willing to do p tattoo dispel my
suspicions that you're under the
influence of any type of
narcotic you willing to do that okay do
you have any injuries that about head
injuries have you had any previous
concussions not that I medically seek
attention for yes I mean uh medical wise
might have had a concussion have you
have you had with the past say 10 24
hours 10 24
hours
um
[Music]
no
actually face the car spread your legs
for me face the car spread your
legs spread your legs
damn
girl
I
down she right hm
she's it's camera get off bro I oh you
guys are going to steal my
laender
yeah you want to try that oh you want a
choke oh you want to choke me out girl
you want to choke me out girl
holy oh you really want to choke me out
girl B I was not doing nothing to you
you want to choke
me I
you give me the 28 one more time
I thought they said they had it
h find grandparents phone number because
last time one of you guys took me to the
mental hospital my grandparents could
not find me for
weeks okay and
you officers were like oh you're going
to be okay you're going to say this is
but all you guys
do
that's going to be a fun
ride yeah man I can still hear screaming
I can still
hear
jeez wasting your time CU you just a me
you're blue life isn't America blue life
is
J it is not a matter it is not a
privileg you chose to be a
car what are you going to do to my car
what are you going to do to my car what
are you going to do to my car you know
what everything is going to be fun I'm
going to get bailed out and
girl I'm going to have a I'm going have
a good two weeks dip out this mother
Place bro I can't wait so genuinely
genuinely thank you thank you for
letting me finally be free and giving me
such BS of capitalism to the point where
I'm just like wow I really nothing
really gives a cops don't give shit
nobody but to meet their quotas and they
pick and choose when they want to be
nice but like at the end of the
day whole
ass over
here oh you you're going to TI me down
sir all y'all want of me
[Music]
is blue lives matter
bitch it's a choice to be a cop it's not
a
live